The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
DENNIS FREEMAN: OK.
So last time, the idea was to
think through a different way,
or in fact, several
different ways,
to think about
discrete-time systems.
Today is a crash course to do
the same thing in CT systems.
So last time, for
the last week, we've
been looking at different
kinds of representations
for DT systems.
Difference equations, because
they're concise and precise.
Block diagrams, because they
let us visualize the signal flow
paths.
And operator expressions,
because it lets you
treat systems like polynomials.
What we'll see today is that
that same kind of strategy
works precisely.
The strategy, not the answers.
The same strategy
works precisely for CT.
We'll have a concise,
precise representation
in terms of differential
equations, which I'm sure you
already know all about.
But we will also develop the
notion of a block diagram
so you can visualize
signal flow paths.
And we'll have an analogous
operator, the A operator,
that will let us treat the
systems as polynomials.
So that's the overview.
Because it's so
similar, we'll be
able to do all of
this in one lecture.
So that's what I mean
by a crash course.
So this is Introduction
to CT in 50 minutes.
So you already know a lot about
how you'd represent systems
as differential equations.
You've seen this
in other classes.
You should have seen this
sort of approach in physics.
You should have seen this sort
of approach in math, in 1803.
So we're to assume
that you already
know how to think about
differential equations.
And what we're going
to do is skip ahead
and think about the alternative
representations instead.
So just like in DT,
where we thought
about block diagrams,
which gave us
a way of thinking about
signal flow paths,
we'll have the same
sort of idea in CT.
The big difference,
you can anticipate.
I mean, if the CT [INAUDIBLE].
In the difference equation,
the fundamental operation
in the difference equation
was a delay operation.
If you contrast
that to a CT system,
a fundamental
operation is not delay.
You know from 1803,
you know for physics,
you know from lots
of other exposures,
that the fundamental
operation is differentiation.
And so the blocks will not
be built out of delays,
but will instead be
built out of integrators.
Apart from, that the
block diagram structure
looks extremely similar.
And we'll be able to apply
the same idea that we
did in DT, to simplify the
representation of the block
diagram by thinking
in terms of operators.
The operator has to
similarly change.
So the new operator,
the operator
that we use to
represent a CT system,
we'll call the A operator, A is
intended to mean accumulator.
The thing that's in my mind
when I say the A operator
is this tank.
This tank accumulates water.
And you can think
about the relationship
between the height of the water,
and the input and output rates
by some differential equation.
But the point is that the
tank itself, the system,
accumulates.
And that's what we want
to have in our heads
when we think about
the A operator.
So the operator is going
to be like the r operator.
You will apply the r operator
to a discrete time signal
to generate a new
discrete time signal
that we shifted to the right.
That's what r
meant, r was right.
So right shift operator.
Here, you apply the A
operator to the X signal.
X is now CT, continuous time.
And when you apply the A
operator to a signal X,
it generates a
whole new signal Y
that is everywhere equal
to the indefinite integral
of the input signal.
So the A operator is, start
with the input signal X.
And integrate it with regard to
time starting at minus infinity
and going up to t, that's the
t value of the output signal.
Simple.
So let's see how simple.
So here's a bunch of block
diagrams written in terms of A.
Here's a bunch of
differential equations.
Figure out the
correspondence, if any.
OK, traditionally, it seems
that people are quiet.
So before you start, say
something that has nothing
to do with 003 to you
next-door neighbor.
It has to have nothing
to do with 003.
And then figure out which of
these bottom diagrams, number
1, 2, 3, 4, or none
of them, corresponds
best to the correspondence.
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
OK, you've got 30 seconds
to answer the question, now.
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
Well, that killed everything.
OK, everybody raise
your hand and tell me
which of the five available
answers, 1 through 5,
best illustrates
the correspondence.
Raise your hands.
Let me see how many
of you figured it out.
Remember, if you're wrong, you
can blame it on your partner.
OK, it's more than 95% correct.
How do you think about it?
What do I do first?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DENNIS FREEMAN:
[INAUDIBLE] So what do
you want me to look at first?
This diagram, that equation?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DENNIS FREEMAN:
Write an equation
for each of the diagrams.
How would I figure out an
equation for that diagram?
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DENNIS FREEMAN: So what's coming
in and out of the plus sign.
That's very good .
So let's focus on [?
that ?] coming out first.
Us.
What's the name of that signal?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DENNIS FREEMAN: Well, I
can think of two names.
That's why it's a
good idea to look
at what's coming in and out.
One way that I could name
this would be with reference
to the A operator.
If I know that what comes
out of the A operator
is capital Y, what goes
into the A operator?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DENNIS FREEMAN: The derivative.
So if I know that what comes
out is Y, then what goes in
must have been Y dot.
But that [? also ?] has to
be the output of the adder.
So what were the two
inputs to the adder?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DENNIS FREEMAN: X and--
py.
So y dot, the thing that
goes into the accumulator,
has to be the same as X plus py.
So y dot is X plus py, so
there's a correspondence
between these two.
Everybody sort of get the idea?
We can do the same
sort of thing here.
What's the name of that signal?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DENNIS FREEMAN: [? Shout. ?]
AUDIENCE: Y dot over p.
DENNIS FREEMAN: y dot over p.
Exactly.
So that one is going
to be y dot over p.
And that's going to have
to be the same as x plus y.
So if you clear
the fraction here,
you would find that
y dot is px plus py.
So there is a
correspondence that way.
And you can do the same
sort of thing down here.
It looks a little bit different.
What's this?
This says that the output
of the adder, y, the output
of the adder here is y.
So y must have been x plus what?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DENNIS FREEMAN: So p
times the integral of y.
And I'd like to write that
in a differential form,
so I could differentiate
term by term
to say that that's the
same thing as y dot is
x dot plus py.
So y dot is x dot
plus py, so there's
correspondence that way.
So the answer is 1.
OK?
Everybody's happy
with them that?
So the point is that the
differential operators
look very much the same.
You can use the same
kind of reasoning
that you did for difference
equations with r.
Of course, the
operators are different.
And just like r, you can
think about these things
as polynomials.
So if you think about this
feedforward system that's
now CT, not DT, the
feedforward system
says that I can construct W by
taking X plus A X, X plus A X,
where that's X plus
the the integral of X.
Then I could think
about the Y signal
as W plus the integral
of W. So that's this one,
y is the w plus the integral w.
And now I can substitute
instances of this into here.
So this w expression
could go in there.
And that gives me this.
If I integrated this
w expression once,
then I would get
the integral of that
plus the double integral of
that, so that gives me these.
And I think about those things
in terms of A's, and I get
precisely the same expression.
So the idea is,
just like r, you can
manipulate operator
expressions in r,
like they were polynomials.
You can manipulate
operator expressions in A,
just like they were polynomials.
And the reason I can say that
is that, if I think through all
the properties of
polynomials, I can draw
an isomorphism between the way
the system would have behaved
and the way the polynomial
would have behaved.
And in particular,
here's three statements
that have to be true.
If the operator
expressions were supposed
to behave like
polynomials, polynomials
have the property that
the polynomials in A
should commute.
Polynomials should
have the-- the A
should have the
distributive property,
multiplication over addition.
And polynomials
should associate.
And if you think about
each of those in detail,
the operations that
would correspond
to what you've put
in the block diagram
have precisely those
same relations.
So that's the outline of how
you go about proving something
like this.
But the takeaway message
is the operator expressions
in A obey all the rules that you
would expect from a polynomial.
So, second question.
Think about these two
systems, and think
about the notion of equivalent.
Equivalent here is going to be
just the same as it was in DT.
In DT, equivalent [? man,
?] if all of the right shift
operators started at rest, that
is to say their output was 0,
we will have the same
kind of notion here.
At rest is going to mean
all of the integrators--
integrators have a starting
value, an initial value.
If those initial
values are all, 0 then
we say that the system
started at rest.
We have that same
kind of proviso.
Given that proviso,
then all of the operator
expressions behave
like polynomials.
So determine k1 so that these
two systems are equivalent,
given that definition
of equivalence.
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
So anyone have an answer?
So how should I choose
k1 if I want those two
systems to be equivalent?
Yes?
Raise your hands.
OK, it was a trick question.
So now, given the additional
information that it was a trick
question, revise your answers.
Ah excellent, excellent.
Instant revisions.
Wonderful.
OK, what was the trick?
[INAUDIBLE] got it.
What was a trick?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: It would be minus 1.6.
DENNIS FREEMAN: It should
have been minus 1.6.
Yes.
So what do you do?
What do I do first in order to
answer a question like this?
[INAUDIBLE]
[? Right, ?] so translate
the block diagrams
into a differential equation.
That's a good approach.
Because what we'd like to do
is figure out an equivalence.
The equivalence is not trivial.
So in fact, the
equivalence is easier
to think about if
you do polynomials.
You could try to
manipulate the blocks
to make them look the same.
That's actually hard.
It it's pretty easy
to do it if you
think about the block diagrams
being represented as operators.
So you can look at the first
one and you can say, OK.
W is the signal that comes out
of A operating on an X minus
0.7W.
So that's what
that's adder says.
And you can similarly
do this box.
It looks the same.
Treat them as polynomials
and you can reduce it
to some equivalent form.
Does everybody have the
gist of what's going on?
Same thing down here.
The equations look a
little bit different.
But it's the same idea.
You figure out what are
the constraints imposed
by the blocks.
The output of every A
has to be the integral
of the thing that went into it.
The output of every adder has
to be the sum of the two things
that went into it.
Figure out all
those constraints,
reduce them to polynomials,
and then manipulate them
as though they were polynomials.
And the polynomial manipulation
shows that minus k1
should be 1.6, OK?
[INAUDIBLE] should
be a minus 1.6.
Point is, it's easy.
If you know polynomials,
you know the answer.
That's pretty good.
So we're doing something
completely different
from polynomials.
But we're able to
use the intuitions
that we get from polynomials
in order to do the problem.
There is one remaining problem.
Something that is
harder than it is in DT.
Probably the hardest part of CT.
And that involves
thinking about what
should be our basis signals.
In DT, there is a
really good candidate
for that, which we call
the unit sample single.
The unit sample signal
is the simplest possible
non-trivial DT signal.
By which I mean it is 0
everywhere, except one place.
If it were 0 everywhere,
we would call it trivial.
So in order for it
not to be trivial,
it has to be non-zero
at least some place.
The place is non-trivial.
It is at n equals 0.
And the value that it is,
given that it can't be 0, is 1.
So the unit sample signal is
the most simple non-trivial DT
signal.
So what we need is
the equivalent for CT.
So here it is.
Define a signal in CT that
is 0 everywhere except 0.
And at 0, make it [? 1. ?]
So is that a good choice?
And I hope I've
biased my presentation
enough so that the
answer is obviously no.
So the real question
is, why not?
Can somebody think
of a good reason
why this is a poor choice
for a building block signal?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DENNIS FREEMAN: So you
would need infinite gain
to go from 0 to 1.
That's sort of true
for the r thing, too.
You have to go from 0 to 1.
It's in 0 time.
That seems hard.
Any other ideas?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DENNIS FREEMAN: Not continuous.
That's also true.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DENNIS FREEMAN: The
integral is always 0.
That's a problem.
So it's just not going to
be a very useful signal.
OK, what am I doing?
I'm trying to figure out
a basis signal that I
would use in block diagrams.
My basic block diagram
is this integrator thing.
Mine is infinity to t on tau.
So I'd like to put
something in here.
But if I put that signal,
what did I call it?
W. If I put W into
an iterator, what's
the output of the integrator
after you integrate W?
0.
Well, that's a problem.
It's not a very
good basis function
if the very first operator I
go through turns it into 0.
Everyone see that?
That's a problem.
This is the problem in CT.
If you guys figure out the
next slide, you're done.
CT's easy.
So what we do is think
about defining a signal that
would have the property
that it behaved as though it
had those desirable properties.
What would have to happen?
We'd like a signal that
had some amount of area.
Because that's
what this thing is.
This is an area operator.
We would like a signal
that didn't have a 0 area.
The W signal has 0 area.
Bad.
We'd like a signal that
doesn't have zero area.
In fact, if we wanted it to
be the simplest possible,
then you should
have an area of 1.
But we'd like it to be
zero almost everywhere.
How do you do that?
OK, well, the way you can do
it, and the way we will do it,
is think about building a
signal [? with ?] a limit.
What if I had a
pulse signal that
was 2 epsilon wide and
1 over 2 epsilon high?
The area would be 1, regardless
of the value of epsilon.
And if I shrunk epsilon to be
a very small number, say 0,
if I think about the
limit, as epsilon
gets smaller and smaller
and smaller and smaller,
then I approach the
condition I'd like to have.
The signal is 0
everywhere, except 0.
Now, it has a
horrendous value at 0.
But, oh well, I'll sweep
that under the rug.
The important thing is
that, when I integrate it,
I'd like it to give me one.
That's the important thing.
Everyone with me?
That's the hardest part in
this part of the course.
If you get this, CT
systems are a breeze.
So this is a different
kind of a signal.
The idea is to incorporate in
it two seemingly contradictory
things.
It should be 0 almost everywhere
and the integral should be 1.
So there is no such thing.
This is an idealized signal.
This is something that we
think about in the limit.
It turns out that we
can get a lot of insight
by thinking about this signal.
But it is important to
realize that it is only
defined in a limit.
So we will write it.
Since it's so useful, we
will write it this way.
We'll draw a little arrow.
The arrow is supposed
to connote in your mind,
this thing goes really high.
It goes so high that telling you
how high it is is meaningless.
So instead, to the side, we
tell you what's the area of it.
What would come out
if you integrated it?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DT [INAUDIBLE]
decompose an [INAUDIBLE]
signal into a series
of [INAUDIBLE] Can you do the
same thing with [INAUDIBLE]?
DENNIS FREEMAN: Yes.
And that will be something
that we spend a lot of time on,
because that decomposition
is not trivial.
But it is possible.
So the question was, can we
decompose arbitrary signals
into sums of these things?
And the answer is
absolutely yes.
That's why we like it.
OK, so the first
thing to think about
is what happens if
you put, now, instead
of W, let's put delta of t,
the unit impulse function.
What happens if you
put the unit impulse
function into an integrator?
Well, if you integrate the delta
of t, so if my input x of t
is delta of t, and if I
want to think about y of t,
which is going to
A operating on x?
So think about what would be
the answer to this integral
for times less than 0?
Well, the system started
the rest and the integrator
turned on at 0.
What's the value of the
answer of the integrator here?
0.
It started at 0 back at
minus infinity some time.
Started at rest.
There was no input.
So the answer is 0.
So the answer is going to be
0 up until something happens.
During that brief epsilon of
time, a unit of area went in.
So what's the output of
the integrator become?
1.
So at that time it became 1.
And then what's the value
as you go forward in time?
1.
It got stuck at 1.
So the most primitive signal
that we'll think about
is the unit impulse function.
We'll denote that by delta of t.
And it has the property that it
goes through our most primitive
block.
Delta goes to a
unit-step And unit-step
is so useful that we'll give
it a special name, u of t.
U means unit-step.
And with that, all
of these systems
now make sense, in the same
sense that DT systems did.
So for example, if I have
a feedforward system,
I can think about that as
having several signal flow
paths going forward.
And the output of
the signal, when
stimulated with
a delta function,
is the sum of all
those different signal
paths that I can think of.
So I can express the
input-output relationship
by dysfunctional relationship.
Everybody sees that?
Or I can just think about
all the different signal
flow passed through here.
What would happen if I
had a delta function here?
Well, here's a signal flow path.
Here's another one.
Here's one.
For signal flow
paths, I have to think
about ways the input could
turn into the output.
If the input went
through the top half,
the output would be delta.
If the input went through, the
path the output would be u.
If the input went
through this path, u.
If the input went through
this, it turns into u,
and then it goes through
another accumulator, what
happens when you integrate u?
tu.
If this is u, and if you put
that in through an integrator,
that integrator, like
all the other integrators
we'll talk about, unless
we tell you otherwise,
is initially at rest.
Therefore, the
output started at 0.
Because u is 0
for t less than 0,
it persists at 0 until
something happens at t equals 0.
At which point, the
input becomes 1,
and the integral of 1 is t.
So we will usually write that
this way, meaning it's t.
So we will write as
a shorthand times u.
That's a strange thing to do.
It's just very convenient.
It's convenient,
because normally,
when you have a function, so
that last function, this one,
is a signal that does this.
So we will call that tu
of t because, obviously, t
is that signal.
We don't mean that.
We want to lop off the
part that came before 0.
Multiplying by u
of t is a quick way
of writing lop off the
stuff that came before 0.
That's all that means.
So we'll write that that way.
And you can see that, by
thinking about signal flow
paths, and by thinking about how
this basic signal, this basis
function, goes
through the system,
it's easy to figure out the
response of such a system.
Just like in DT,
feedback is different.
So now, we have to think
about what would happen
if there's a feedback loop.
So it was crucial,
when I was doing
this kind of an illustration,
that it was feedforward only.
I could decompose all
of the signal flow paths
into a finite number
of forward-going paths.
This is harder.
This happened in DT, too.
We had to figure out how the
DT system was going to work
when we had a feedback path.
And it was more
complicated, and we
had to fall back
on thinking about
sample-by-sample propagation of
the signal through the system.
And we'll do the
same thing here.
In order to figure out how
to think about signal flow
through such a diagram, through
a diagram that has feedback,
we'll think about
falling back to 1803.
Something we can trust.
Something we all loved.
Nod your heads yes.
Make me-- reassures me.
Fond memories of 1803.
So it's pretty simple
to think about how
you would solve that system by
using an 1803 type of approach.
Convert the system into
a differential equation.
We've already done that one.
Then from the form, we will
usually, in this class,
use the general method of
solving differential equations,
which is--
What's the general method for
solving differential equations?
They may not have
told you in 1803.
What's the general method of
solving differential equations?
Guess!
Yes.
So the general method is guess.
If you can guess, plug it in
and it works, you're done.
The kinds of systems
that we will look at
will be linear systems.
They will have a
single unique solution.
If you can find it by
guessing, you're done.
And we will prove
later in the course
that all systems of this
class, where I haven't really
defined what this class is,
but if you made a system out
of adders, gains,
and integrators,
and only those parts, then that
system will always be linear.
And the solutions
can always be written
as complex exponentials.
We'll prove that later.
I'm not going to
bother with it now.
For now, you would say, OK.
First-order linear
differential equation
with constant
coefficiency, the answer
is obviously an
exponential function.
So you plug that into the
differential equation.
You figure out the
constraints that
would have to be solved
for this to be true.
And the answer is that y should
be e to the pt [? of ?] u of t.
Should start at 0.
And there should be an
exponential after that.
And the p shows up as the
exponent in the exponential.
What we'd like to do is
develop an alternative way
of thinking about that,
using the operator approach.
So a completely different
way to solve that problem
would be to think about,
write an operator expression
for this.
OK, so Y is A times
the signal that
results when you add x to py.
Solve for the ratio Y by X, and
you get an operator expression,
a over 1 minus pA.
Just like in DT, we
have to figure out
how we would think about that.
It's an implicit operation.
It's telling me that
if I knew the answer,
the answer is the signal that,
when operated on by 1 minus p
is the integral of the input.
But I don't know the answer.
So that reasoning
doesn't quite work.
The reasoning that I used to
solve the feedforward question
doesn't quite work.
So I have to think of a
different way of doing it,
just like we did in DT.
And the same solution works.
Not surprisingly.
A behaves like a polynomial.
R behaves like a polynomial.
After you turn it
into a polynomial,
you can't tell if you
started with a or r.
It's a polynomial.
So for that reason, exactly the
same stuff that you did in DT
works.
That's why we can solve
everything in 50 minutes.
It's all the same.
So in DT, we thought about
this as being a series.
You could figure out an
ascending series, a power
series, that's equivalent
by thinking about something
like synthetic division,
Taylor series, whatever
you're comfortable with.
But whatever you're
comfortable with.
This, A over 1 minus pA,
take the A out front.
Then you're left with
1 over 1 minus pA.
Think about that
is Taylor series.
That's 1 plus pA, plus
p squared A squared,
plus p cubed A cubed, etc.
Done.
Now I know what the system
functional looks like.
Now I've got a
feedforward system.
So I can use the technique
from the other side.
What happens if you put delta
into a system whose functional
representation is A?
So you get a u.
Let me skip that one.
That's on the next slide.
What happens if you put in--
no, that's right.
I did that right.
OK 1 u.
Sorry, I'm confusing myself.
This A turned into that u.
What happens if you
put it into pA squared?
So the first A
turned delta into u.
The second A turns u into tu.
And so I get this term.
So the pA squared
turns into ptu.
The p squared A cubed turns
into a half p squared t
squared u, etc.
So what I've done
is I've thought
of a way of constructing this
output signal from the input
signal without ever
using calculus.
I started with a
solution based on 1803
that's strictly calculus.
I just redid the whole problem
and didn't use any calculus.
And the method works
just the same reason
that the our method worked.
In the r method,
when we were thinking
about the simple feedback
with an r system,
every loop around the feedback
loop generated one new sample.
Here, every loop
around the CT loop
generates one more
contribution to the output.
You put a delta function
in, it gets integrated once,
and you get a u function out.
[INAUDIBLE] [? first ?] in
this symbolic representations.
The first thing that comes
out is A times the input.
Second thing that comes out is
A squared p times the input.
Third thing that comes out,
p squared a cubed, etc.
Every time you go
through the loop,
you pick up one more turn.
Now, think about it
in a time domain.
You put in a delta function.
The first thing that
comes out is a step.
The second thing that
comes out, and gets
added to the first
thing that comes out,
is integrate, multiply by
p, and integrate again.
So that's this term, p times t.
So we get the unit step
from the first term,
which looks like this.
We get the linear increase
from the second term.
We get a squared term,
we get a cubed' term.
And voila, we get the series
expansion for e to the pt.
No calculus.
It's purely thinking
about how you
would think about constructing
this system by a series
representation for spinning
around the feedback loop.
So that's an insight that comes
from thinking about the system
as a functional representation,
as a polynomial.
Polynomials can be
expanded in Taylor series.
Therefore, systems can be
If you change the
sign of p, you'll
notice that that previous
example exploded.
So we got to an
increasing exponential.
If you change the sign of
p, it's not too surprising
that what will happen is
that it will converge.
So here, symbolically,
the first signal
is a unit-step just like before.
But now because
of the minus sign,
there is a negative on this pt,
so you get sloping downward.
In the squared term,
it's still positive.
So that breaks it up.
But the cubic is
now downward again.
And you add an infinite
number of those
and you get another exponential,
this time a convergent one.
So the point is that
it works extremely
like the way the DT stuff
did, except now the basis
functions are different.
The basis functions are
derived from this thing, which
is the unit impulse function.
And the things that come
out of the integrator
are steps and ramps and
parabolas and stuff like that.
So in r, the basic input signal
was the unit sample signal.
And what came out on
each revolution around--
for each cycle in a feedback
system, what came out
was a successive delay.
Here, we get
successive integration.
Delay was the
fundamental operator.
Integration is the
Successive delays,
successive integrations.
And we get the idea that we
have convergence and divergence,
just like we did in DT.
Except now, the shapes of
the regions are different.
So if the p, which we
will later call the pole,
by complete analogy
to what we did in DT,
if the pole is in
the right half plane,
then the system's
response is divergent.
If the pole is in
the left half plane,
the system's responses
is convergent.
So it looks just like DT.
We think about this
as signal flow paths.
We think about how
feedback gives rise
to an infinite number of those.
In DT, each time through, it
gave one unit of delay in CT.
It gave one unit of integration.
The method is the same,
the answer is different.
So what we got is
tremendous similarities.
Differential equation compared
to difference equation,
block diagram compared
to block diagram.
Integrators instead of delays.
Functional functional,
A instead of r.
Pole, pole.
Mode, mode.
Fundamental mode.
Here, the fundamental mode
was a geometric sequence.
Here, it's an exponential
function of time.
And we've got different kinds
of regional convergence.
Signal converges for poles
in the left half plane.
Signals converge for poles
inside the unit circle.
Same idea, but some differences.
OK, so [INAUDIBLE]
have time think
about this for 30 seconds.
We now have two
representations, R polynomials
and A polynomials.
I'm giving you four
examples to think through,
and your job is to
figure out which
of those functionals correspond
to convergent responses
when excited by a unit sample
or a unit impulse signal.
So, how do I think about this?
Is this convergent or divergent?
What do I think about?
Step 1.
Convergent.
How did you get that?
Yeah.
It's this one.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DENNIS FREEMAN: So factor.
It's polynomial.
You get a pole at minus
1/2 and a pole at plus 1/2.
They're both inside
[? the unit ?] circle.
They both converge.
How about this one?
Same equation, same answer.
Kind of.
Same poles, minus
1/2 and plus 1/2.
Convergent or divergent?
Divergent, because the
regions are different.
One of the poles is in
the right half plane.
Divergent.
How about this one.
Where were the poles?
Minus 1/2, minus 3/2.
Outside unit circle?
One of the poles is
outside the unit circle.
Diverges, because of that pole.
Minus 1/2 and minus
3/2, same poles.
Both in the left half lane.
Convergence.
That's the point.
So they worked very similar.
But there are differences.
And now in the
last three minutes,
the last thing I want
to tell you about
is that even complex numbers
work just the same as in DT.
So think about a system
that's slightly harder.
Here, I can represent this
by this kind of relationship.
So F equals Kx, but F is MA.
So 801.
And so I generate a block
diagram or a differential
equation or however I
want to think about it.
And I can solve for the answer.
What I'd like to do
is think about it
in terms of the
functional representation.
So I just think about,
take this system
that you're familiar with.
We did this on
the first lecture.
Turn it into a
differential equation.
Turn that into a
functional representation.
Now, I want to think about how
you would solve the functional
representation.
The idea is just
like before, factor.
But now the trick is that
the factors become complex.
So one way you can
think about this
is to force the second order
system into a canonical form.
The canonical form for DT
was 1 over 1 minus p not R.
For CT, it's A over
1 minus p not A.
So I want to make factors
look like that, because I
know that here, the response
looks like p not to the n.
Here, the response looks
like e to the p, not t.
If I can coerce
it into that form,
I already know the answer.
So that's what's
illustrated here.
I coerced this into that form.
And then I'll know what
the answer looks like.
Just like we could in DT,
substitute R goes to 1 over z.
In CT, we can substitute A
to 1 over s, and solve for s.
We get the same answer.
Same as we did in DT,
except now we call it s.
So the poles to this system
are plus or minus j constant.
For convenience, I'll call
the constant omega not.
So then I have a pole
at e to the j omega not.
And another one-- so I
have a pole at j omega 0
and a second pole
at minus j omega 0.
By that argument,
the fundamental modes
are e the j omega not t and
e to the minus j omega not t.
Just like in DT, the complex
poles gave complex modes.
Here, the complex
pole, j omega not,
gave a complex mode, cos
omega t plus j sine omega t.
And just like DT,
the system conspires.
So that started out being
mass and spring system.
Obviously, it's not going
to have an imaginary output.
The system conspires so
that the imaginary parts
of the different fundamental
modes kill each other off.
And the answer is a real number.
So even though the mode, even
though the pole is complex,
the multipliers are
complex, this sum is real.
And if you just think about
what that sum is, by thinking
about how complex
numbers work, you
get an expression that looks
like omega not sine, omega not
t.
It's a little more
fun to think about how
that evolves as a series.
If we do a Taylor
series for this,
we can represent it that way.
And the series, then,
the first term is t.
The second term is a t
cubed, which goes down.
Then there's a fifth and
a seventh and a ninth.
And if you keep adding up
the terms, amazingly enough,
the series representation
for the operator expression
is the Taylor series
expansion of the sine wave.
Just like we would
have expected.
Again, here, the response
looks like e to the p not t.
If I can coerce
it into that form,
I already know the answer.
So that's what's
illustrated here.
I coerce this into that
form, and then I'll
know what the answer looks like.
Just like we could in DT,
substitute R goes to 1 over z.
In CT, we can substitute A goes
to 1 over s, and solve for s.
We get the same answer.
Same as we did in DT,
except now we call it s.
So the poles to this system
are plus or minus j constant.
For convenience, I'll call
the constant omega not.
So then I have a pole
at e to the j omega
not, and another one-- so I
have a pole at j omega not
and a second poet
minus j omega not.
By that argument,
the fundamental modes
are e to the j omega not t and
e to the minus j omega not t.
Just like in DT, the complex
poles gave complex modes.
Here, the complex
pole, j omega not,
gave a complex mode, cos
omega t plus j sine omega t.
And just like DT,
the system conspires.
So that started out being a
[? mass ?] [INAUDIBLE] system.
Obviously, it's not going
to have an imaginary output.
The system conspires so
that the imaginary parts
of the different fundamental
modes kill each other off,
and the answer is a real number.
So even though the
pole is complex,
the multipliers are
complex, this sum is real.
And if you just think
about what that sum is
by thinking about how
complex numbers work,
you get an expression that looks
like omega not sine, omega not
t.
It's a little more
fun to think about how
that evolves as a series.
If we do a Taylor
series for this,
we can represent it that way.
And the series, then,
the first term is t.
The second term is a t
cubed, which goes down.
Then there's a fifth and
a seventh and a ninth.
And if you keep adding up
the terms, amazingly enough,
the series representation
for the operator expression
is the Taylor series
expansion of the sine wave.
Just like we would
have expected.
Again, I solved the
differential equation,
a second order differential
equation, this time
without calculus.
All I did was polynomial math.
And so with that, I'll
finish just by saying,
today, what we did was
introduce, and basically
finish, CT.
Because there's such a
strong analogy between what
we did in DT, and how we'll
approach thinking about CT.